[Music]
and if it fits your macros news oh my
god who knows about macro Oh charlie
submitted by sexy time I like too far so
that's a time I lied a lot that's a good
one dude
a man proves you can eat anything you
want
after losing 32 pounds on an all ice
cream diet only ice cream like nothing
else but ice cream ice cream and either
like and or protein shake and alcohol Oh
what about vegetables forgot about the
protein shake part which is the
constipated as [ __ ] his liver is gonna
fail it he's all [ __ ] up internal
would you hydrated what kind of
vegetables is for eating nothing
I think alcohol is only carb he is
[ __ ] up wife's cream has a too but ice
creams carbon fat that's it is a protein
up front yeah maybe a little bit on the
milk but it makes it I'm down for a no
ice cream diet don't sure every day Oh
soft-serve ice cream is absolutely where
well trim some swirls oh yes look back
that's the [ __ ] Elysee dude it's cool
oh yeah David so you know I didn't I
don't even notice that until somebody
else put it well I hate good nice on the
subliminal I'm like yup what he done
hahahaha oh yeah I don't act like you
didn't know you Duke your partners it
shut the hell up of course I did this
guy named and to me 32 years old from
Colorado
he is a stunt dietary slash youtuber so
[ __ ] does that mean
so he does his extreme diet the all
french fry diet or the all o stunts
dieter using in my head so he started a
channel called ice cream and abs back in
2011 the reason you started this is the
YouTube channel if you wanted to prove
that you can eat any
to lose weight as long as you burn more
calories than you consume I thought
everybody knew that
I don't think everyone knows that yeah I
do you guys know because you guys are in
that industry but a lot like a lot of
the people don't know about this
something even they even teach you that
in like nutrition in high school just
you know if your daily calorie intake
for average is what 2,000 then it goes
if you consume over that then you're
going to get overweight if you come you
consume under then you're going to lose
weight or whatever right but then I
don't think anyone pays attention in
school because I I forgot that fact
until later on his first diet
dieting thing that he did was a 30 day
diet 50% of his calories came from ice
cream he lost 2 pounds a week and he got
abs the second time he did another 30
day diets at this time was only
fast-food same thing he lost 2 pounds a
week and got AB and in his most recent
study this he did 100 days of only
eating ice cream protein shakes and
alcohol the reason why he added alcohol
and so this is because he wanted to
debunk the diet myth that you can't cut
body fat if you're drinking alcohol he
was on a 2500 calorie diet 2,000 of
those calories came from ice cream and
the other 500 came from either protein
shake and or alcohol and so he ended up
losing 32 pounds and he did a blood work
after this entire diet and he all ice
cream he put that coming up cookies and
cream now he found out that his
cholesterol and his glucose levels
improved well weird but he did feel
terrible
her cold yes he thought that brain
freeze every day yeah he does admit that
while he was doing this diet he felt
terrible every day he started to losing
interest in everything and he felt tired
all the time a hundred days of ice cream
way to like kill the thing that's
awesome yeah I don't even know if I
could do that I love
yeah be nice crew four times a week
right now man yeah I think I can but I
have to eat with other stuff like if I
have a regular food I got ice cream
every day which I think I do
he actually what makes ice cream so good
is eating it after something so savory
and you're like you have like a big
steak dinner and you're like this guess
I'm asking guys I'm saying towards the
end of this diet he stopped going to the
gym and he even stopped working on his
YouTube channel because he just got this
pressed I guess like from the diet he
just didn't feel good anymore she says
that he did lose more muscle than fat
told you the message here is not that
this is an ideal diet to permanently
sustain it specifically to show how an
energy deficit overrides specific food
sources when it comes to weight / fat
loss that is true but it doesn't equal
health because obviously he's like
[ __ ] miserable he feels like [ __ ]
you're only consuming like straight-up
fake-ass sugar and milk and like that's
why it's kind of weird that his glucose
level is improved and also his
cholesterol like the bad cholesterol
went down the good one went up so it
also depends on what if they find one so
like pre ice cream diet let's say it was
crazy fried foods Carl's jr. or whatever
really every day so if he was doing that
for like two months and then his
cholesterol level is really high then I
think with the ice cream of course is
going to drop but I think so those
numbers relative to each other don't
really mean anything because you can
alter all those things you know let's
take a look at the man this is what
Anthony looks like oh you look right now
and after his diet how come we look like
been taking drugs for 330 days
really look like before and after the
challenge are you working out - yes he
was that's that's the main thing that
you can consume whatever you want is
more and more than cow Oh God crackhead
ha ha ha ha ha [ __ ] funny a Savannah
devil looking like IP ice-cream 400 days
poor guy well improving that point I
think elections I don't think his point
was in the point of help either
it's just weight loss weight loss yeah I
yeah at the end of the day though I mean
it's really what he's proving is
discipline that's what it is no matter
what you do is all about discipline to
me I am absolutely done it got me a - I
care too much about what my tastebuds
like and not enough about what I look
like in the mirror I know do my do I
told you we got this in reverse body
dysmorphia yeah I could like I have a
belly now but I'm so focused on my arms
and what's positive that I'm like damn
my chest hasn't been like this in a long
time I'm like hey just look and she's
like you're still fat I'm like where
where can't tell dude if you have to
keep putting on weight before each diet
- that's a good question so maybe eating
a bunch of [ __ ] putting on a [ __ ] Conway
these cholesterol goes up it's a good
lesson for a lot of people I don't know
if for your body to lose weight all you
have to do is have a caloric deficit or
if your maintenance 2,000 cards whatever
at 1,800 calories and you maintain that
you are going to lose weight but that
doesn't say anything about health does
it say anything about fitness or doesn't
say anything about muscle levels or
anything like that I think ideally
you're supposed to consume you know
clean sources and whole foods that are
natural to the human body along with you
know like having like a nutrition coach
or something helping you with your macro
nutrient and even your micronutrients
and their micro for like all of that
though yeah that's real Chinese food
every day to cut day you can have and
just don't get the rest no Chinese food
is actually pretty healthy it's pretty I
know what I'm talking about that [ __ ]
fasting [ __ ] yeah
that deep fried pork chop oh can you
give me the extra grease yeah I like it
when Chinese people go you know this is
not enough grease get the comb scotch
and then they cover that [ __ ] all over
and it comes out glitter [ __ ] with the
msg layman Yong tubes too with that god
damn [ __ ] I wish working out got me
that excited I know Ryan I feel like I
don't know I'm trying to get into the
mind of a bodybuilder this is their art
you know this is being sculpted they're
really into it so like it's like you
know what [ __ ] my taste buds I could eat
that chicken breast or whatever I got
whoo I could do my discipline because
every day when I look at this I'm like
that's what I'm imagining and I'm like
damn I wish I could have that with
bodybuilding there's like that certain
I'm not saying this a negative way it's
like you know that you have to have a
certain amount of vanity you mean like
this has to affect your mood like how
you look you know I'm saying absolutely
yeah because food affects my mood so if
I want all right I want good sushi and
if somebody gives me [ __ ] fish pink
sushi I get up I get pretty sad yeah I'm
like what is this [ __ ] piece of
garbage get this [ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
face I'm still going to eat that paper
but still how long have you been
tracking that crow semi oh oh wait yes I
like in your lifetime Oh seems like a
year and a half and we have never done
it before
nah I used to not eat I find it really
hot date so I actually don't you yeah I
don't track mappers - ah wait wait wait
I'm tracking macros to actually eat say
no you just need a ticket with me for
you get you can y'all just be getting
chubby for no reason dude I mean after I
already ate
and we talk about food while we're
eating I love eating after I ate you
never sat before pregnant ever
those are on the tip and the deme world
101 I do then y'all need to get pregnant
yes it was like that when I was pregnant
no I wasn't not even when I was pregnant
I didn't like food sweets to me he's
like I can eat sweet all day like oh she
was a candy free yeah sweet old a remedy
these are real yes you should have hung
out with me when I was bulking I'll
teach you how to live life have you ever
for dinner go to McDonald's and Taco
Bell oh that is one dinner oh my [ __ ]
double cheeseburger and a taco coke and
a Pepsi so you get both yo this dude
when he was at the restaurant it'll be
him in jail right there sitting there he
goes okay can I get the extra large [ __ ]
please and the lady well bah he goes not
done yet can we also get the pork chop
and rice and then she moved past G or
she goes that's not for her that's for
me and then I get an order a spring
rolled and then some filet mignon tubes
and she walks past deal again like I
already I haven't ordered yet ha ha ha
when this one was bulking it was crazy
to eat it was kind of fun to watching me
thanks for watching just kidding news
guys don't forget to comment down below
we want to hear what you say only it's
positive remember that to watch more
videos go up here baby
ah
[Music]